اهلا بكم من جديد توترات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تضع السودان
على صفيح ساخن خلافات ساحتها منطقه مروي
بالولايه الشماليه قد تنسف معها امال
توقيع اتفاقيه لنقل السلطه التوتر بلغ
ذروته مع وصول اكثر من 100 سياره من الدعم
السريع الى السور الذي انشاه الجيش قرب
مطار مروي هذا التحرك قرر بعض ان هدفه
الانقضاض على المطار العسكري الاهم للجيش
في الشمال لافشال اي تحرك جوي للجيش وعبر
سلاح الطيران اذا وقعت المواجهه الدعم
السريع برره وجوده بتاديه المهام المناطه
بقواته وجاءت بتنسيق مع قياده القوات
المسلحه وبقيه القوات النظاميه الاخرى وهو
ما نفاه الجيش ومع تفاقم الخلافات بين
القوتين العسكريتين الكبيرتين في السودان
بدات القوه السياسيه والمدنيه بالتحرك
سريعا لاحتواء الموقف
لم تنقطع محاولات القوات المسلحه في ايجاد
الحلول السلميه لهذه التجاوزات وذلك حفاظا
على الطمانينه العامه وعدم الرغبه في نشوب
صراع مسلح يقضي على الاخضر واليابس لان
هذه الانفتاحات واعاده تمركز القوات
يخالف مهام نظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
وفيه تجاوز واضح
للقانون ومخالفه لتوجيهات لجان الامنيه
واستمرارها سيؤدي حتما الى المزيد من
الانقسامات والتوترات التي ربما تقود الى
انفراط عقد الامن بالبلاد
مطار مروان
مطار استراتيجي مساند للمطار العسكري
الاول في الخرطوم
يضم قاعده عسكريه جويه تشكل خط الدفاع
الجوي عن شمال ووسط السودان
الجيش السوداني البلاد تمر بمنعطف خطير
بسبب قيام الدعم السريع باشد قواتها داخل
العاصمه وبعض المدن
تحركات الدعم السريع تمت دون موافقه قياده
القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
نحذر القوى السياسيه من مخاطر المزايده
بمواقف القوات المسلحه الوطنيه
نجدد التمسك بما تم التوافق عليه في دعم
الانتقال السياسي وفقا لما تم في الاتفاق
الايطالي
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع نرحب بضيفي من
الخرطوم الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين
المحلل العسكري ومن الخرطوم ايضا الدكتور
يعقوب عبد الكريم نورين عضو هيئه
الاستشاريين لقائد قوات الدعم السريع اهلا
بكما ضيفي العزيزين واسمح لي ان ابدا مع
ضيفي الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين فريق
فتح الرحمن الخلافات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع ليست وليده اليوم
مؤخرا طفت الكثير من هذه الخلافات على
السطح لكن ما الذي اوصل الامور الى هذه
المواجهه العلنيه والمفتوحه بين الطرفين
وما طبيعه الخلاف من وجهه نظركم بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش
طيب اول حاجه شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا جزيلا
اللي ضيفك الكريم وتحياتي للمشاهدين
اولا كل هذه الزوبعه وكل هذا الامر الذي
يتحدث عنه الناس الان ويجدون شماعه مروي
وشماعه ان الدعم السريع يقف مع جانب سياسي
والاخر يقف في طرف اخر ولا ينصعد تعليمات
القياده العسكريه كل هذا الامر وهذه ما
تراه الان من شائعات تغطي الاسافي السبب
الاساسي فيها ما وافقت عليه المؤسسه
العسكريه في الاتفاق الاطار للمناقشه
القضايا الخمسه هل كانت مطروحه
انها هي المعضله المفروض تتفقد بعد ذاك
الناس يمشي لي قدام
الكلام ده حصل باء خاصه في ورشه اصلاح
الامن والعسكري لما تقدمت ورقه عن لدعم
السريع كانت شامله كانت
قدمت حلول
لاصلاح الامني والعسكري ومن ضمن التوصيات
اللي قدمتها الورقه وازعجت
بغايه النظام البايت في داخل القوات
المسلحه اللي هي التوصيه التي نصت على ان
يجب تنقيه الجيش والدعم السريع والاجهزه
الامنيه والشرطه كلها من عناصر النظام
البيض
طوالي داخل الجيش الصخور بتاع النظام
البائده الموجوده داخل الجيش طوالي اخذ من
هذا الامر زريعه وبدو يشعر في النيران حتى
مساله بالامس لمن القوات الدعم السريع
وصلت مروي استقبلونا الجيش وفطروا معاهم
وقائد الحميه كان معاهم موجود وكانت بعلم
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه الفريقة
والبرهان وبالتالي مساله في العيون هذه لا
يعني لا تنطلي على الشعب السوداني مروي
ليست
خارج السودان مره ليست افضل من دارفور
ليست افضل من الشرك ليست افضل من الحلفه
ولا افضل من المياه الازرق يعني القوات
موجوده فيها قل لي متى تحرك الجيش عشان
يحل مشكله واحده قبليه كانت او مشكله نزاع
او غير اي مشكله تحصل في البلد ويتحرك لها
الدعم السريع مباشر وبيمشي بحله الدعم
السريع وبموافقه الجيش ما الذي يمنع ان
يكون الجيش او يكون الدعم السريع موجود في
مروي زي ما هو موجود في دنقره وزي ما هو
موجود في العينات وزي ما هو موجود في
المثلث وزي ما هو موجود في قاعده
الشيفروليه الى اجابات على هذه الاسئله
الشرعيه والمخدرات وغيرها الدكتور يعقوب
فريق فتح الرحمن كيف تردون على هذه
الاسئله المطروحه من قوات الدعم السريع
اولا نقول ان كل الانفتاح للدعم السريع في
اي مكان في السودان يتم بالتنسيق مع
القوات المسلحه وبعلم القوات المسلحه
التدخل الدعم السريع في حل اي نزاعات في
اي مكان في السودان يتم ايضا بالتنسيق مع
القوات المسلحه وبعلم القوات المسلحه لكن
يا عزيزي لا يوجد فيها نزاع مر لا توجد
فيها مشاكل قبليه ولا اسميه ولا مناطقيه
ولا اي شكل من اشكال المشاكل مروي منطقه
مستقره ولا يوجد سبب اصلا لوجود قوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه وحتى ان كان
هنالك سبب لوجودها كان يجب ان يتم
بالتنسيق مع القوات المسلحه المعضله الان
انهم تحركوا دون علم القوات المسلحه ودون
التصديق من القوات المسلحه ضيفك يتحدث عن
ان ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري تحدثت عن
تنقيه الجيش من عناصر النظام البيت انا
اقول له وان ارادك ويشوفه بالاسماء اعطيها
له القوات المسلحه الضباط الذين
فصلتهم من الخدمه بسبب انتمام للنظام
البايت في الدعم السريعه لانهم ضباط في
الدعم السريع فكيف
تغلبون الصوره هكذا الذين كل الذين كانوا
يتبعوا للنظام البائد وكانوا يتبعوا
للحركه الاسلاميه في القوات المسلحه تم
التخلص منهم من الرواه المسلحه منذ العام
2019 ومنذ عام 2020 لا يوجد الان في
القوات المسلحه ومن ينتمي الى اي حركه او
اي تنظيم سياسي ايا كان شكله الذين التخلص
منهم القوات المسلحه لمختلف الاسباب سوى
كانت اسباب اقتصاديه يعني اقصد فساد او
اسباب اخلاقيه او حتى انتمال النظام البيت
تم استيعاب داخل الدعم السريع والان هم
ضباط في الدعم السريع يعني كيف كيف نقلب
الصوره هكذا ونتحدث عن ان الجيش يحتاج الى
تنقيه اقول لك الجيش والامن والشرطه هذه
اجهزه دوله وليست اجهزه نظام هذه الاجهزه
توالي
ايا كان شكلها
ولكنها لا تخضع لاي تنظيم من التنظيمات
ولا توالي اي جهه غير الجهه التي في
السلطه السياسيه الان وقوات الدعم السريع
لمصلحه من تقوم بهذا الامر من وجهه نظركم
فريق فتح الرحمن
قوات الدعم السريع للاسف يعني
اوعزوا لها بانها يمكن ان تكون بديل للغات
المسلحه يمكن ان تكون موازي للغات المذهله
الاولى ثم بعد ذلك تقوم بديل للقوات
المسلحه وتتسيد المشهد بالكامل ولكن للاسف
الذي او عزل هذا لو توضح الرحمن هم يريدون
قوات الدعم السريع للاسف مطيه يحققوا بها
جنداتهم وهم يمسكونهم ملفات كثيره على
الدعم السريع يعرف متى وكيف يمكن ان
يتخلصوا من الدعم السريع بسهوله وبالتالي
الان يتخذهم
فريق فتح الرحمن اخرى غير السودان للاسف
وغير الشعب السوداني هل هذه الجهات التي
تتحدث عنها جهات داخل السودان ام خارجه
هي جهاد داخل السودان تعمل لمصلحه اجندات
للاسف والان الصوره اصبحت واضحه جدا لمعظم
المتابعين للمشهد السياسي في السودان
للاسف
اذا كان لديكم معلومات عن هذه الجهات
لماذا
بالنار
المخاطره واللعب ما بين الدعم السريع هذه
لعبه خطيره جدا وستحرق البلاد وستحرق
النطاق الاقليمي وساحتحرقها ومهم قبل كل
شيء لذلك انا اعتقد انهم من العقل ان
يبتعدوا انا احاول هذا النظام
كيف تردون على كل هذه الاتهامات
ومن له مصلحه بتفجير هذا الخلاف بينكما
اولا اخي الكريم حتى مروي التي يتحدث عنها
الشعب السوداني ده عنده قيمه القيمه
بتاعته انه لما يجيك
بتكرمه والجيش الموجود في مروي اكرم قوات
الدعم السريع وفطر معاهم وامبارح تمام طيب
وفي هنالك الان في مروي اذا كان ضيفك
الكريم كان يتحدث عن الوجود المصري موجود
في مدني يعني لا يمكن ان تكون هنالك
تدريبات مشتركه تستمر لمده ثلاث سنوات اي
تدريبات مشتركه هذه كويس موجوده في قاعده
مروي الان الطيران المصري موجود وقبل ذلك
حدث كثير من الامور داخل السودان وتم ضرب
المواطنين في الجزيره ابا في طيران مصري
يعني معروف الكلام ده وبالتالي نحن بنفتكر
انه اي شيء بيهدد امن البلد دي مسؤول
الدعم السريع
دكتور ما هي فرص تحقيق بين خلينا معاي 40
ثانيه
قبل على لو سمحت لي قبل لو قبل القفزه
للمصالحه لو سمحت لي ويتحدث عن ان الجيش
ليس فيه نظام باين من قال له ذلك من 89
الى الليله اي دفعه خشت الكليه الحربيه
كانت مؤدجه وكانت بموافقه القائد تتعامل
معزول بيضعوا
للتنظيم تخش الكليه واذا منتمي للتنظيم
اعتذر منك انتهى ذهن الوقت تماما دكتور
يعقوب عبد الكريم نورين اشكرك كنت معنا من
الخرطوم والشكر موصول للفريق فتح الرحمن
محي الدين المحلل العسكري
نهايه بانوراما الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات